[Musique]
sur les sommets du maïdo à plus de 2000
mètres d'altitude ses racines et ces
écorces de végétation calcinée rappelle
les incendies de novembre 2020 175
hectares de plaines et de remparts sont
dévastés par les flammes et des gars qui
impose la fermeture du sentier qui colle
la brèche la porte d'accès vers mafate
depuis le maïdo sentier est primordial
pour les habitants de roches plates et
des orangers selon l'itinéraire le plus
court pour sortir du cirque pour leur
vie quotidienne donc nous avions cette
urgence cette urgence mais qui était qui
s'est accompagnée de prudence il aura
fallu presque dix mois pour observer et
dégager les roches instable sur cette
falaise fragiliser le département avec
l'appui technique de la nf à travailler
à sécuriser ces cinq kilomètres de
sentiers les ouvriers forestiers de
mafate on reconstruit à la main une
partie du sentier
par taper dans le talus amont et voilà
c'est sur deux mètres de hauteur à la
barre à mine à la pioche on burin et à
la massette on a travaillé même au
bureau et puis on a profité des rochers
que l'on décoller pour les garder elle
est posée sur le sol enfin on aperçoit
un épaulement un épaulement rocheuse qui
permet de tenir le sentier sur sa partie
plane où les gens vont poser les pieds
un kilomètre de son tir est
particulièrement abrupte pour sécuriser
ce passage de voix de main courante sont
installés sur 60 mètres de long alors
une main courante c'est un câble qui est
contre le talus errements sur lequel les
gens posent leurs mains et se tiennent
de façon serrée au monde peu moins serré
suivant leur leurs impressions mais qui
paieraient qui permet d'éviter toute
chute ou ses travaux en fait montre que
le département et le nf ou un
partenariat qui est assez fuite parce
qu'il faut réagir rapidement aux élèves
qui est notre bras armé vraiment experts
en la matière puisque ce sont des
travaux qui sont très complexes avec la
nécessité de mise en place de
dispositifs
le sentier maintenant praticable
permettant ainsi aux randonneurs de
plonger vers mafate depuis ses remparts
du maïdo
[Musique]